one fantasy i've always had is being a
girlfriend with you i'm not kidding
i i just i love you so much i love you
as a person i love you for your
profession can i girlfriend out with you
for a second i would love nothing more
okay
[Applause]
oh my god this is this is the best day
ever this is why people love your show
because it feels like you get girlfriend
time with drew barrymore
and i'm gonna get girlfriend time with
elizabeth moss my hero okay let's do
this all right now i want to like know
the woman behind the woman with funny
random little facts like favorite song
right now oh
lord probably the new lord album which i
just kind of just i know it didn't just
come out i don't think but i've just
started listening to it yeah i don't
have a favorite song yet but the album
i'm really into i'm a little late to the
game though i think but anyways i love
lord lord good choice great choice my
daughter is obsessed with the green
light song yeah and i think that's from
a that's from an older album but that's
her music crack right now um okay uh do
you have a favorite uh cocktail moscow
mule see i love this in a copper cup oh
yeah
now i know what gifts
um what makes you laugh
oh my brother
my brother who i think is the funniest
person ever i love them
because i have two daughters and all i
care about in this world is them having
each other
and being close and fostering that yeah
so this is important information for me
okay thank you okay good i guess we hope
but what really ticks you off oh
what to oh you know what ticks me off
this is an honest answer
when i am when people say oh i didn't
want to bother you with that oh
that really ticks me off because
eventually as you know as a as a
producer a person who's running anything
you know it's going to be your problem
eventually it's coming your way but when
it comes your way it's kind of sometimes
too late and it's a bigger problem so i
i feel like there's a condescension in
that that maybe women experience more
than men i don't know
but that is it really takes me off like
bother me
it's fine i can take it
um okay you have two cats lucy and ethel
yes and
is it true you adopted them on a film
set yeah they were found on the street
in brooklyn actually in park slope i
know
little old angel
look at them i love orange cats i know
they're so sweet yeah so they were found
on the street and then we used them in
this film that i did um called listen up
phillip and indie film and i took them
home and i thought i'll find them homes
and nine years later here we are
it's true once you bring them in no
so stupid i don't know what i was
thinking
um okay um one part maybe in history
from film or television that you've
watched is there anything you would ever
want to play oh that's already been done
oh my god that's hard because everyone
everybody always does such a good job
i will say one of my favorite movies is
gravity uh with sandra bullock and
though although i would never do as good
of a job as she did in that film
untouchable she's incredible i would
love to do something like that
that was you know required such an
amount of technical perfection such an
amount of concentration
it's almost entirely a solo performance
yep she uses almost entirely her own
imagination i think that would be a
really interesting challenge to do
something like that and anything sci-fi
i love sci-fi really yes okay
this needs to happen yes you could
direct it i would love to
oh my god are you kidding you can just
direct it with like the world's greatest
actress
[Music]